full count we'll see if the
brewers sandy ellich i suspect they will
i agree they're going to send them right
here they don't oh and you're
at a weak spot upstairs chasing high
fastballs and he just chased one for
strike three and miana picks up a big
strikeout almost like a little cutter
yeah
yelling goes now on the pitch grounded
to the glove side of ceno who makes the
play here's miguel ceno
droughts nobody on
the ball two strikes
the breaking ball takes care of business
as cenote goes down swinging here's
sogar it is now retired six straight
brewers
and
a foul tip and avila hangs on it's a
strikeout two down strikeout number two
that looked like the split finger and
the o2 he got him strike three maeda
blows a fastball by garcia he strikes
out swinging and maeda has now retired
eight straight milwaukee batters no
score between the brewers and the twins
burns looking sharp early
buxton since when on the ground nice
just in smoke and you're right you gotta
hurry because buxton can fly
playing a little bit off the first base
line had to cover some ground
was able to do so one and two or two
outs managed scoring position for the
twins burns trying to take care of
polanco and the 3-2
got him yanning over
struck him out with the change up corbin
burns matching those zeros headed for
another relatively low scoring game both
starters have done a nice job so far
and ends up breaking out yellow anyway
and strikeout number four and here it is
santa's looking to miss
back-to-back strikeouts five now on the
night
on the outside edge he struck out the
side
three straight one two three innings a
scoreless game pitching duel between
burns and miami it has struck out five
men in a row
and there's strikeout number six in a
row
brawn out on strikes for the first out
of the fifth how about that two and two
to narvaez
the seventh
strikeout in a row tying a club record
60th year of twins baseball and miata's
tied a club record tonight
and he set the club record with his
eighth straight strikeout
congratulations great job
go to the bottom of five in minneapolis
it's a 0-0 ball game
to the gap in right center field and the
first hit of the game goes to our eyes
he'll go to second
he's got a lead-off double and you know
liner to center his first time up that
was caught by garcia and here he hit one
to the gap
let's see if we can get him in here's
miguel snow
and a base hit left center field headed
to the gap arrives around third he'll
score the big man digs for second base
and he pulls in with a double and the
twins take the first lead tell you what
he fought off that fastball that was
barreling in on him and showed off his
strength and they're loaded up now for
nelson cruz
he struck him out breaking ball and
burns does get out of the inning with
just the one run aloud the twins leave
them loaded
now back to the top of the order and
officer garcia pitch number 77
back to myada
six innings of no hit ball we've
completed five and a half one nothing
minnesota can you pitch any better than
this young man has here tonight no hits
first six innings set a twins record
with
eight straight strikeouts
got him
seven no hit innings for kenta maeda
and now with a 10 strikeout night twins
are coming up in the home seventh
clinging to a one-nothing lead now it's
polanco
who will flip over and hit from the
right side of the plate against the
left-handed throwing brent suiter
and a fair ball down the line about that
adrianza around third he'll score
and a little more breathing room for
kenta maeda big run bad at end right
there by polanco here is yurius two
ground ball outs
chopper
to our eyes eight no hit innings for
kentu maeda and now adriansen with
runners on the corner squeeze play and
it works beautifully again adrianza will
get a base in
they tried it yesterday and scored a run
and
adrianza drops it down beautifully and
rosario scored into myada
three outs away from just the sixth no
hitter
in twins history
liner to center into center field
and sogard breaks up the no-hitter
everybody applauding in the twins dugout
and here comes rocco bulldelly to get
the three outs rogers will have to
navigate through the best hitters
milwaukee has they're loaded for the
brewers with nobody out here at the
plate the pitch
swing and a fly ball center field
sinking fast it's down a base hit
that'll get sogard home the brewers have
their first run of the game and the
tying run in scoring position here comes
the o2 pitch
and that is hit on the ground
he'll get to play in second and the turn
gets away
from gonzalez here comes yelling and
this game is tied oh man wow
how about that it's gonna be a throwing
here it'll be an rbi for jericho winning
run at second one out bottom 10 3-3
score
he struck him out slider at the top of
the zone and gonzalez you can't argue
balls and strikes he did and he's gone
and so now two away and jed jerko the
batter breaking ball tapped
jerko hustling
and a good play by polanco to throw him
out jorge polanco with a great play
charging the slow roller now second and
third of the calf one on one
liner to ride kepler with a diving catch
and jerko came down the line and can't
tag and score what a great catch fight
max kepler jericho came down the line
about 30 feet and then had to retreat
and therefore couldn't tag infield in on
the right side winning run 90 feet away
in byron buxton and now polanco's coming
up to try to be the hero
slow roller here comes buxton and he's
safe and the twins win the game all
right so there's your new extra inning
rule